each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello all thank you for coming we are
very happy to have this chris byrd chris
is actually no stranger to MSR he's in
turn twice with us in srr he's actually
going to talk to us today about his
research interests in socio-technical
congruence primarily based on teams and
on software systems thanks da Qi so yeah
so I'm student UC Davis finishing up in
the summer and this talk I would kind of
want to tell you my background is why I
do what I do what I have been doing
recently and also what I what I hope to
do in the future so i'll start off and
tell you a little bit about myself so i
got here by kind of the traditional
means i did my undergraduate in computer
science and towards the end of my
undergraduate career and also while my
wife was finishing up her degree worked
for a large tech company writing
software and i work with some some
really bright people some very capable
managers but there are some things about
the projects how the projects that have
worked for were run they're a little
disconcerting and when i talked to some
co workers and managers we kind of had
this running theory that when managers
make decisions a lot of times they're
making their decisions based on you know
their intuition of what they think and
this kind of anecdotal evidence but as
we know the plural of anecdote is not
evidence and so as I was kind of
disheartened by some of what was going
on and so when I went back to grad
school I really wanted to do something
about this and so kind of what I was
thinking was there's got to be a better
way to run software projects a more
principled way and is there some way
that we can can work towards making
decisions based on actual real evidence
so I'm going to make an assertion I
don't think anybody here would argue
with that developing software is is
expensive and time-consuming if you talk
to people this probably isn't it true at
Microsoft but but you would know better
than me but a lot of projects ran over
budget and when you talk to developers
most of them ship late at just this week
we have another victim of something
shipping I think a week late and the
rumors are on the net that the iPads
exit super late due to a software issue
and not a hardware issue so this is very
relevant today and if you look at the
literature the number that's classically
given is that eighty percent of the time
and money is spent after release so this
is just to get there and then then you
have to deal with this and I should
really point out I don't think it's
because we don't have smart people
working on the problem that you've got
bright people here at Microsoft and also
other plate places so I don't think it's
that we have done people I think it's
just a hard problem so that's how we
have software engineering research right
we want to make this better and at a
high level and there's two things that
software engineering tends to try to do
not all of it does this but what we want
to do is in some way increase
productivity so this may be in terms of
processes that may be in terms of tools
to help people may be in terms of like
language abstractions that allow people
to be more productive but we don't want
to sacrifice quality right that that's
painful if you're shipping bugs that can
have financial reputation impact as well
okay so this is what we want to want to
get to so clearly the next thing to talk
about is a cholera outbreak of 1854 so
this is related to give you some
background in 1854 a cholera outbreak
that some said is was the worst outbreak
in in the kingdom and there were some
false ideas at the time about how
cholera was spread so one idea is my
asthma which is this idea that you've
got this poisonous gases going around
and you're in its way you're gone
sometimes you know well we deserve it
God comes and smites you and you get
cholera and some people said this is
life it just happens you deal with it
move on so the government at the time
said nothing we can do we just have to
have to deal with it but fortunately
there was some people at the time that
had other ideas so this is Jon Snow he
was a surgeon at the time and he had
some ideas about how caller was spread
and its effects and he he he saw this
opportunity to kind of test some of his
ideas he was under some constraints if
you have an idea about the way that
disease is spread typically in medicine
if we have questions we can run like a
double-blind
clinical trial where you want to give
people cholera and other people not
giving the cholera and see who dies and
then say oh now I know but you just have
to watch what happens and see so we had
these constraints and he has to watch
after terminamos so we had some
hypotheses so I think this is how
cholera is spread and then what he did
was he went around and interviewed
families he talked to people who had
family members that have passed away and
those who were relatively healthy and he
also also collected Geographic data and
is if there's a very famous map called
the ghost map that he made of the area
where the outbreak occurred in the
little black dots represent families
residences where people had passed away
from cholera and generally he observed
the community there's some interesting
things that he found if you look online
at this research that he did he found
some some key events that led him to to
come to the conclusion he color was
passed by water and he identified the
Broad Street pump this is this well in
southern England and so he went to the
authorities and said look I think the
water here I think this is the source of
your outbreak and he convinced them to
take the handle off the pump so no one
could get water and immediately out the
outbreak stopped and this is really
considered one of the watershed events
in epidemiology spawned the field and
some of the methods that he used are
still in use today okay so so why does
this matter for us right hopefully we're
not dealing with people living and dying
but I work under the same can some of
the same constraints that dr. snow
worked under he couldn't conduct these
trials he had to observe a phenomenon
and gather whatever data he could to
test some hypotheses about how things
worked so we care about living people
living and dying but my research isn't
necessarily about that but we care about
our software projects that fail and
those that succeed right we want more
windows seven is actually gotten a
pretty good reception in the marketplace
so this may be a success and this is
area and five rocket that actually blew
up as a result of a software failure so
you want less of these exploding rockets
and more of these windows sevens right
so so we do is we use what Jon Snow use
what we call the empirical method and
there's three main steps to the method
the first is that we gather data
typically regarded to our outcomes
measures software quality and
productivity and then all
so whatever factors we think are related
to those and then we examined
relationships so both quantitatively and
qualitatively try to understand what's
going on and then based on that we can
make changes to processes maybe we build
tools to help developers and managers so
we can you know have an impact make
things better so does anybody care about
this a lot of problems we can solve more
than we have time for we want to make
may look for solutions to problems that
matter and so really if you ask the
right questions then people do care and
so some of the questions I've asked have
been based on my prior experience
working in software and also experience
that other people have had and the
gripes that they've had about what
they've encountered and the goal being
that if we can take this empirical data
if we can improve processes maybe it
turns out that working a nine-to-five
work week is better than putting in
hundred-hour blitzes at the end of a dev
psychol we can talk target resources if
we know that certain parts of the system
are more prone to failure and hopefully
we can improve the quality and the
productivity of our developers and does
it matter yeah there's a lot of money
riding on this so 2008 is with software
was a 300 billion dollar market so
there's a lot of ways to look at this
and if you look at the literature is
replete with ways to address this
problem my kind of perspective is to
look at the people so this is burnstow
strip kind of the father of c++
programming language he says design and
programming our human activities if you
forget that all is lost and if you
remember Jon Snow who was interested in
disease but what did he do he looked at
the people and so that that's what I do
so I'm going to present some some of my
results today but to give you an idea of
what my whole time graduate career
spanned the things that I've looked at
of looking at open-source software and
how it works a lot of people are
interested in in how it works is it
really this bizarre with everybody doing
everything and magic just comes out or
is it some more organization I've look
at defect prediction so both using
attributes of the people working on
software to predict defects but also
looking at the effect of the quality of
the data that used to make defect
prediction we found that that that has a
big effect and then also process
and the effects of process used on
software quality and it's not just
software I've also got some other things
so I've looked at collaboration in
computer science research found that
different different areas of research
kind of the collaboration patterns are a
little bit different and I'm an
empiricist I love sports so I actually
have a submitting a paper about NCAA
football and I'm happy to talk about
this ad nauseam if anybody's interested
love college football okay so today I'm
going to talk about three things looked
at distributed development ownership and
expertise and also how how we think open
source software works so the first one
there's a stupid development hurt code
quality so unless you've been under a
rock you realize that in the tech sector
at least offshoring has been a really
hot topic and if you followed the 2004
elections this actually came up in some
of the political platforms offshoring
from the US it's a big it's a big issue
and there are some people that have some
ideas about it so this is Tom Allen he's
at MIT he studies innovation and in the
workplace and he's developed what he
calls a 50-meter phenomenon and this is
that the idea is that when you have
people working in a very creative and
innovative environment when you have
people even as far as 50 meters apart
you see dramatic decrease in their
ability to the frequency of
communication and the richness of
communication and so this is 50 meters
the question is what happens when you're
talking about 5,000 miles do we see in
effect does it hurt software quality and
when you talk to developers about the
issues that they face when when dealing
with people that are operating remotely
they have a lot of a lot of issues that
they'll raise but all in leading back to
the claim that look you know quality
will suffer if you distribute
development especially around the world
and in this study what we showed is that
it can be done with a little effect on
quality not that it always will but
there are ways to do it so Windows
Windows Vista is really a great
candidate to study to ask this question
I don't have to give people here what
your background right you had thousands
of people that worked on a very large
project the thousands of individual
pieces and we can compare the pieces
within one
object rather than different projects so
we're really trying to compare apples to
apples and avoid some of the confounding
factors looking at two individual
projects it's very large and definitely
distributed around the entire world so
we have this question Jon Snow had some
ways of gathering data to test his
hypothesis well what do what gay data we
need to get together it's kind of four
pieces initially start with just the
source code so we know who contributed
source code to every binary in Vista so
binary is an executable a shared library
and a driver we know who wrote every
line of code next this dialogue does
have a bad connotation but people that
work here know that the information
related to crashes help help the manage
that Microsoft make decisions about what
to fix and who's being affected which
crashes are the most important so this
is kind of our outcome measure of
software quality next we have the org
chart we know who is working where when
they were contributing code to Vista and
then last we actually have the
geographic data so this is a map of
precisely where i am actually and the
ovals indicate buildings that are served
by the same cafeteria so of course I
don't have to describe as much to you as
I have to head to the other people but
so on with these these four pieces of
data we can really answer this question
so what we did was we we bend binaries
based on the level of distribution so
the very lowest level you have the
building level so this is where most the
developers work in the same building if
you work in the same building it's very
easy to walk next door des I'm going to
question about maybe an interface you
may run into people just informally
you've worked together you've probably
been at the whiteboard together in
meetings talking about your design
cafeterias where you have developers and
buildings that are served by the same
cafeteria so still not too hard to walk
next door you can probably arrange a
meeting fairly quickly you can have
meetings over lunch the campus level
here in redmond it can take a while to
get between buildings you may be less
familiar with someone that works at
another building probably want to
schedule a meeting you know a day in
advance
and then locality so like you have the
Seattle locality it takes a while to get
between sites you may not have even ever
met face to face something that's
working on something that you're working
on if you live in the same locality but
not on the same campus and then things
start to get bad pretty quickly at the
comment level you start to begin to deal
with time zone issues meetings are very
difficult they almost always have to be
conducted electronically and then at the
world level you've gotta fly it's
expensive you start to do with cultural
issues there may be sites that don't
have any overlap in terms of working
hours and and the idea behind this is
kind of harkens back to Tom commands
work is that look as the distance
increases it becomes harder to
coordinate to be aware of what everybody
is doing and to be managed and so we
started off looking for looking for a 50
meter rule of software so what we did
was we we took these levels and we
created five different splits and said
look first we'll say that co-located is
all binary that developed by developers
in the same building and everything else
is distributed all the way down to
distribute is only binaries that worked
on by developers across the world and
everything else is co-located so is
there any split here where we see a
dramatic difference in software quality
so I'll show you the split for the
differences for the very first split so
two-thirds of the binaries fall over
here and co located and then one third
is in distributed and these
distributions look a little bit
different because there's a lot more on
the left and on the right but the actual
distributions are there there's there's
not a strong difference between the two
and I'll just tell you right now I had
to take off the numbers because people
outside of this organization can't see
them but the peak on this side is the
same thing as a peek over there and so
although you have different mass the
distribution is fairly similar and so we
conclude just from visual inspection we
don't see a huge difference yeah I enris
are equal right so some are huge so like
tiny so ha isn't it
so it's chocolate you interested
bokutachi spidery the number of failures
I read and then you can so you would
infer from that that co-located can be
much worse than distributed but if you
know at Microsoft I may be a TD Ella
it's entirely blown inside here in
redmond and with less important perhaps
or whatever is distributed and now yeah
so you're going to discuss all that yeah
I will exactly ask that slide so
it struggled a lot of people and I
should mention so this is actually these
this is not worse than that so the x
axis is the number of binaries and
failures or excuse me y axis as binaries
X is among the failures and so although
there's like more in this peak than that
pic the proportion the actual
distribution density distribution is
about the same between them but you're
right binaries are different and that's
something that we looked at so I'll get
to that in a little bit so we decide to
take kind of a more principled protein
just looking at pretty pictures and so
we use linear regression and this is
kind of the data that we use look like
this so if for every binary we included
the level of distribution it there's no
reason to believe that there's a linear
relationship between buildings to
cafeterias the campus so what we did is
we encode it each one as a binary
variable in our model and so you'll
notice that we don't have any category
four different binaries in the same
building that's kind of our baseline so
we're comparing quality of distributed
by Nuri's to those that result in the
same building and then I our output is
quality software quality so we measure
that number of failures in the six for
six months after release avista okay so
this is what our model came out and
don't be afraid I'll actually interpret
was this what this means so the the two
pieces of information that were
interested to the percent increase so
this is the percent increase in failures
relative to binaries developed by
engineers in the same building so as an
example if you look at binaries
developed by people in different
cafeterias but the same campus we see a
sixteen percent increase and over over
on the right is the significance that's
just the likelihood that what we're
seeing is just due to the noise in the
model so lower values are better and
point 05 is about the cutoff for saying
that something is statistically
significant so in almost all cases we
see that it's significant sixteen
percent is is nothing to sneeze that
it's not as high as
what we were expecting to find but you
know that is an increase so we conclude
look there there actually is a little
bit of an increase in failures when you
distribute development but interestingly
Jim herbs lab did a study in 2003 that's
kind of similar to ours he looked at
productivity not quality he also found
that when it was distributed the output
variable went down so when in cases
where people were less productive but
then what they did was they controlled
for the number of developers in the
teams so essentially if you have 10
people in the same building or 10 people
scattered worldwide you're going to see
an increase the same increase relative
to five people in one building and so we
asked the same question what happens
when you control for team size so again
we're using similar data but now in
addition to the level and the failures
we add the number of people that worked
on a binary and the story changes a
little bit so again this is a result of
the new model the two things to pay
attention to our first the birthday and
increase is dropped dramatically the
highest is in the different localities
but we can't even tell if that's due to
real data or just noise in the model the
only one that statistically significant
is different campuses you see a six
percent increase so it's dropped which
means a lot of what we were seeing was
the fact or just larger teams and larger
teams tend to be more distributed so
what we conclude is look there is a
small increase but it's actually mostly
attributed to the size of the team
rather than the level of distribution
okay so now back to two Patrice's
question because it's a really good
question and when I've presented this
result two people both inside and
outside of Microsoft they said well look
maybe management knows we should
distribute the the simpler things those
are you know have a lower risk if they
were to fail and so they said we think
simpler binaries are distributed and so
because distribute development is hard
everything balances out and they look
like they're the same well so the first
question how do you find simpler there's
a lot of ways to define simpler
fortunately Microsoft gathers all kinds
of metrics from source code so they've
got measures of complexity measures of
churn sauternes sizes like number of
lines at it's this number of commits
in degree and out degree on the
dependency graph path coverage in
testing all kinds of things and so we
looked at the correlation between these
metrics and the level of distribution
for the binaries to see is do we see
that those that are simpler or more
distributed this is actually a list of
those with the highest correlations as
you can see so correlation ranges from
negative 1 to 1 with extreme values
showing a high relationship and we don't
see very high the highest is number of
developers but this isn't a surprise we
just found that we've been controlled
for the number of developers we're able
to account for more the variance and
failures so from this correlation
analysis it doesn't look like what's
being distributed is actually simpler
you don't see a huge difference but I've
actually found in my research that
sometimes just digging into the data by
hand can show you things that you
wouldn't find just by doing a
quantitative analysis so we actually
looked didn't look at all 4,000 binaries
but we did look at like top 20 lists of
those that were distributed and those
that were the largest and the smallest
look to see if maybe there were
subsystems that were motor stupid than
others and we didn't find anything we
even went so far as to build logistic
regression model say if we include like
all 60 metrics can we predict the level
of distribution and the precision and a
canned recall where we're really bad and
so what we concluded from this is that
at least relative to the metrics that we
use to look at for simpler it really
wasn't much of a difference at all
between the bynars that distributed and
those that weren't so the next next few
question how in the world did they do
this and and why why are we getting
these results but so substance is it it
doesn't take more but to build them cold
okay
it'll be quite a small communication to
get to the same results so yeah that may
be to the degree that it's so depends i
had to find effort right so we did
measure effort in terms of the number of
changes made to code they're clearly
other ways to measure them so like how
often were you having meetings and that
kind of thing we didn't measure that but
I would expect that it's more effort at
least in coordination definitely and
actually so some of the qualitative
factors when we talk to people kind of
bear that out so here are some factors
that we got from managers I should
emphasize we don't know we haven't shown
a causal relationship but the intuition
and people's experiences support the
idea that these this may be some of the
reason why we got these results so first
Microsoft uses liaisons and face-to-face
meetings there's literature that shows
that if people have face-to-face
communication then later when they work
remotely there's more trust there and
you're able to work easier and if you
have liaisons then people know who the
point of contact is in the different
teams next a lot of the senior engineers
it kind of the distributed sites a lot
of them started here in redmond so if
there was a question in Beijing about
what tool to use or why was this design
citizen made or who should i contact
because i don't understand something
these senior people they had a lot of
that information if they didn't have the
answers they knew who to go to and so
they they were kind of taking this
information in their heads with them to
the remote sites during the vista cycle
they had daily synchronous communication
so that means that for sites where
there's no overlap and work they had
people coming in early or staying late
so you could have meetings and talk
about issues before they escalated out
of control and went unaddressed for
weeks or even months and lastly
Microsoft tries to use the same process
in the same tools at least within Vista
I don't know about the other projects
but within Vista they tried to have the
same process uniformly I mean some other
studies they found that if remote sites
are working on their modules
everything's going fine and good until
it comes time to integrate and then you
have problems because people you know
some people ran their tests with their
bills and other people pull from a
different repository system and so you
really run into problems then but Vista
didn't have this because they use the
uniform process
so so what do we conclude well I'm not
claiming that distributed development is
easy it's clearly difficult and talking
to anybody who's done it will tell you
that but after looking at the community
and gathering some data and testing some
hypotheses we found is that it's
possible to do it with a little effect
on post release failures and this is a
good thing right this is this is good
news we have we have a handle Microsoft
least has a handle in terms of the Vista
development on some of the problems that
we face and how to overcome them so
that's collaboration in terms of
distance so I want to talk a little
about collaboration in terms of
expertise as well so in the soft
furnishing literature so I'm interested
in expertise and how how much experience
people have with certain parts of the
code base and in the literature you'll
find that a lot of times people use
ownership as a proxy for expertise so if
you've made a lot of changes to a
particular portion of that code then you
have experience you probably understand
it better especially if you're the one
that like wrote a large part of it and
if you have if you haven't worked with
it then you have low expertise less
knowledge and so the question that I ask
is what happens when you have a lot of
people working on something and those
people have low expertise is is that bad
our intuition will tell us yeah that's
probably not a good thing and next is
ownership related to defects so if you
have a binary that's clearly owned by
someone is that better than having a
piece where is kind of shared ownership
among a large team and then does the
process matter does the developments
tell that you use is that related to the
relationships of ownership and quality
so and i'll define ownership more
formally a little bit later so I'm going
to make a bit of a generalization say
that there's a development process
spectrum and I'm kind of generalizing
here because it's not just this one
dimensional spectrum but for the sake of
some first steps this does clearly on
the commercial side eclipse is a project
that kind of lives in this hybrid land
if you look at the development activity
it's mostly owned and controlled by IBM
but it does espouse some open source
principles that's under an open source
license and it accepts country
from the community at large so call that
kind of a hybrid and then Firefox though
lately it's being moving to more of a
corporate controlled entity for this
study we looked at older versions of
Firefox or it followed more of an open
source style I should I should point out
there is no like one open source method
of development no one commercial so I'm
kind of generalizing to a bit here and
so the question that I asked is well how
do these differ so I need to define some
ownership here terms here so on a on a
per component basis I say a major
contributor someone who's made at least
five percent of the total commits so the
idea here is that these major
contributors probably have expertise
they've worked a fair amount 5% probably
sending up a warning flag right this
magic number we actually tested it at
other sensitivities or other levels for
this threshold so 2% all the way up to
ten percent with similar results so we
don't think it's a function of of just
this magic number so similarly a minor
contributor has made some about five
percent or less of the total commit so
these are people that make few commits
we think they have less expertise and
then the ownership for a component is
the proportion of the Kim it's made that
by the person that made the most commits
and a graph probably explains us a
little bit better so this is a graph for
one of the shared libraries in Vista and
I've ordered the developers by the
amount of contributions that they made
so for this one the top contributor made
41.3 percent of the commits so we say
that the ownership is forty-one percent
five developers made at least yeah five
builders made at least five percent of
the commits and then 12 developers made
less than five percent of the commits so
the idea is that when you've got lots of
these low expertise people this may be a
problem so the first thing that we did
was we just looked did a correlation
analysis just said let's look at these
ownership metrics and look at the
correlation with failures and in this
study was actually interested in in
pre-release and post these failures
because I think and the results show
that there are there are things you can
do to mitigate the effects of ownership
so the interesting finding and we also
included some of the base metrics that
are already collected yeah Rob
oh yeah okay so these are things that
were used that bugs found during testing
or at the end of the QA cycle they were
putting into the issue tracker and had
to be fixed prior to release yeah yeah
sorry thank you good question so there
are some things that are known to be
related to failures and we included
those as well so the interesting finding
was that the number of minor
contributors actually had the highest
correlation of any metric that that we
saw so with with pre-release and post
boost values it's stronger with
pre-release and we found this trend in
all the projects and for all the
ownership metrics that that pre-release
how to hire a stronger relationship so
this gives an idea that were on the
right track but one of things we found
is related Patrice's question earlier is
that those binaries that have a lot of
minor contributors are also those that
are more critical in the system are
larger and so this may not be as big of
finding just looking at a bivariate
correlation so we turn to linear
regression to ask this question because
we want to control want to look at the
effect of ownership when controlling for
other factors that are known to be a
problem so in our model in all cases
except for Vista post-release the
distribution of failures was heavily
right skewed and so when you have that
you have to one of the Assumption linear
regressions that your normals or your
residuals are normally distributed so
when when our output was the log the
logarithm of the number of failures that
assumption was met so we did that
transformation and all but the Vista
pre-release post-release we built a base
model where we had some factors later
the size complexity and sharing and one
of the problems when doing linear
regression is that if you have too many
variables that are all highly correlated
you can suffer from overfitting and
multicollinearity and that can be a
problem so we picked the measures in
each of these categories that had the
highest correlation with failures we did
was so we have this base model and then
we added additional ownership metrics so
we added the number of minor
contributors and said and then ask the
question does the prediction power of
the model go up and then we added
additional we added ownership we also
added a number of others and I can
direct
to the paper so this is work actually
that we just submitted FSC on on Friday
and so to evaluate if if the models get
better when adding this metrics we look
at goodness-of-fit tests and also the
amount of variance in failures explained
ok so I'll give you the results for
Vista since you guys are probably most
interested in that and then high-level
results for eclipse and Firefox but the
details are in our paper so with our
base model we're able to explain about
twenty six percent of the variance in
failures for pre release and then 29 in
post release when we add the number of
minor contributors it adds quite a bit
so we increase twenty percent for the
pre release and twelve percent for the
post rees failures and then when you add
ownership it goes up but not as much we
actually tested adding adding variables
to the models in different orders and it
was fairly consistent no matter what we
did miners had had more of an effect on
ownership but miners also were always
more significant than just adding the
toll just the team size which is total
and so we did this analysis so sort of
this mean is that when we take ownership
into account even when including the
things that we know are related to
failures the power of the model
increases which means it's having an
effect beyond just those standard things
so when we did the this analysis on on
the other projects as well so the
interesting thing that we found was that
the projects that were more on the
industrial side we saw a stronger effect
of ownership on quality so in this case
plus means that the number of failures
went up when the metric went up minus
means that the number of failures went
down when the measure went up so higher
ownership is good more minor
contributors is bad Eclipse you see of
range like medium too strong in some
places because we've tested against six
major releases of Eclipse but although
this is only three projects that sum up
somewhat preliminary we definitely see a
trend here that in places where it's
more industrial where their ownership
policies in place violating these
policies tends to lead in to more
failures similarly the number of major
contributors those who say have more
expertise adding them didn't have a very
large effect yeah
the time how do you define ownership
doing the number of developers see our
ownership is a function of the number of
commits that you've made to code so how
many times you've worked on the code and
if you've worked on the code more then
your ownership is higher the intuition
is that you're more familiar with that
code less likely to make mistakes and
then then the base the things that we
know are related to failures they were
across the board so that wasn't
surprising so eclipse we used these
plugins and we also looked at packages
Java packages and for Firefox we
actually the same thing that you did for
your cross project prediction your FSC
papers would look the kind of directory
level stuff so kind of 22 Fighting's one
is ownership is related to quality but
also the process that you use is related
to has an effect on the relationship
between ownership and quality so we talk
to people one of the questions they had
was why why do we see these minor
contributors what is the reason and so
one of the things that we found in
talking to people is that people would
say well I made this change to this
component I hadn't changed it before
because I needed to because I was trying
to fix a bug that was assigned to this
component that I'm in charge of so we'd
see someone who is a major contributor
to one component he may need to add a
feature fix the bug in the process of
doing that it's like oh well I actually
need to go change the shared library and
so he would be a minor contribute
contributor to a different component and
we would often see dependency
relationships between them so this is
something that the people had hypotheses
about we looked and we actually found
that this happened pretty often one of
the problems in doing something like
this is that you can often see what
you're looking for so this is the type
of thing where you buy like a red car
and then all sudden it looks like
everybody is driving a red car but it's
just because you're looking for it right
and so we wanted to be careful that we
weren't suffering from this so we did
was we did a Monte Carlo simulation to
see how often we would see this just in
a random graph where there was no
attention to these dependency
relationships and so we did we took the
contribution graph so this is an example
contribution graph of some Spartan dumb
people working on things and the all
those are the binaries and what we want
to do is create random graphs with the
same number of the same developers and
the same distribution of major and minor
contributors so this is like my advisor
if he made three major and two minor
contributions we wanted to keep that the
same but randomized what he was
contributing to to see if this
phenomenon this major minor dependency
relationship was real so we did was grab
we use what's called graph rewiring and
in that you grab two edges at random
either both major contribution edges or
minor contribution edges and then you
flip them and so what this does is now
the same number of binaries each binary
is the same number of major minor
contributors same number of people make
the same number of major and minor
contributions but now it's random so you
do this a lot so N squared times where n
is the number of edges and you can reach
a sufficiently random graph well you do
that a bunch of times you generate
thousands of random graphs and see how
often do we see this major minor
dependency relationship in these random
graphs versus what we actually observed
if there's a big difference then that
means that whatever observing isn't just
noise it's a real phenomenon that's
occurring in these software teams what
we found was that we saw this dependency
this major minor dependency relationship
about fifty percent of the time so we
can explain about fifty percent of the
minor contributors to binary so we know
why they're doing acting this way and
when we do this random graphs it was
about twenty four percent of the time so
just given the distribution that some
people work a lot more than others you'd
expect at random to see twenty four
percent so that what that means is we're
really seeing a process we're seeing a
phenomenon that's real that's really one
of the reasons that people are that
non-experts are making changes to code
so that's good because now not only do
we have a result where we know have some
idea of why that result is occurring
which makes it somewhat actionable so we
also decided to dig in a little bit
deeper and replicate a study based on
these contributions so mine pinsker was
here a couple years ago working with
nochi and they built a prediction model
where they looked at the apology this
network of people contributing to binary
they were able to predict which binary
for the most failure-prone like really
high accuracy so eighty-five percent
precision 92 percent recall
in the way that they formulated the
problem random guessing would get you
about fifty percent of the way there so
we asked the question what happens when
you remove the non-expert people these
minor contribution edges so we
replicated the study by removing these I
just swim here as dashed edges to
non-experts and when we did that the
precision that we call call both fell
dramatically so what we conclude from
this is that the topology introduced by
these mighty contributors they're really
important they add a lot of the signal
to the model we also tried it without by
removing the major contributors and the
precision recall did not fall as much so
what does that mean these minor
contributor season these non experts are
part of the reason that that you were
having these failures and they add to
the predictive power of the model so
with this these findings in hand we want
to do what Jon Snow did right we want to
take off the handle and see what happens
so we have some recommendations actually
wrote an internal report that I'm told
went to management I'd like to see you
know if this has been put into practice
and if people have followed these and
see what was the results so three
recommendations the first is that when
changes are made by minor contributors
those changes should be reviewed more
heavily than the other changes and
further those changes should be reviewed
by the people who are the major
contributors the owners and those with
the most expertise there are other ones
that are most likely to spot problems
next in cases where people want to make
a change so maybe you're working on a
component and you see that you need to
change another component you haven't
worked with because your your component
depends on that one where possible
communicate those changes to the people
in charge rather than making the change
yourself so clearly you can't do this
all the time because people don't scale
indefinitely but because it's a
situation where we see lots of failures
being introduced you follow this
hopefully you'll introduce less and then
lastly Microsoft already uses a number
of metrics to decide where to focus
their QA resources at the end but
ownership should be added to these
metrics because we've shown that even
when using these metrics you can
increase your prediction accuracy when
you add ownership so these are
recommendations within
the next step is to see what happens
when you follow these recommendations
does the quality actually get better
okay and so the last thing that I wanted
to look at or share with you is
understanding how open source software
communities work this kind of harkens
back to the question does this matter do
do people really care is this just like
an intellectual exercise to see well we
want to know how this works or do people
really care about this question I think
the answer is yes because there are
companies that are trying to compete
with open source software there are
companies that are trying to embrace and
work with open source software and so if
we understand how these work these can
benefit both parties so first you start
with this premise made by a guy named
Eric Raymond he's this kind of
self-appointed spokesperson for open
source software needs a very famous
essay called the Cathedral in the bazaar
where it characterizes industrial
software is this well-planned
well-executed modular software community
and then you have the open source is
this bizarre we have people just work on
anything they want to morning around
talking to everybody and wonderful high
quality stuff just emerges well Fred
books has has kind of something to say
about this so if you're from Earth
Brooks law it says that adding people to
a software project that's late will only
make it later and one of the reasons
that he gives as support for this
premise is that look you have
communication problems say you have a
project with three people working on it
and that that's all fine and good where
you add three people to it and now the
number of potential communication paths
grows quadratically with a number of
people that you add to it and so if you
have people just working randomly then a
project will begin to fall apart under
the weight of its own communication and
so you have to have some type of
organization or you run into this this N
squared communication path problem
that's going to be a problem so if open
source is really these if it's really
this bizarre community where everybody
works in an ad hoc fashion how they deal
with this communication problem that
Brooks talks about and so the question
that I asked is are there chapels of
organization within this bizarre of open
source
so our approach we started by looking at
the social network there is no org chart
like there is here at Microsoft for open
source and so we looked at communication
on the developer mailing lists to get
the structure next we took some
clustering techniques from the areas of
complex networks and physics and altered
them to to work on our social networks
right to deal with like edge weights
where an edge weight maybe number of
messages sent between people in the
community and they give you an example
of what we found most networks are very
large this is one of the smaller ones
this is pearl and what you see is the
edges represent communication between
people and the boxes represent the
clusterings that we found using this
this technique and then we examined
something called modularity so
modularity is this formal metric it
comes out of out of physics that ranges
from 0 to 1 and values of about point 3
and higher are considered modular for
for networks that are known to be
modular that occur in nature so we did
was it took a number of open source
projects and look to see how modular
they were do they pass this threshold so
we looked at these five projects and in
all cases we saw that that the
modularity was much higher than you
would expect to see by chance and so we
we find is that there actually are
tight-knit groups of people within the
organization organization of open source
or all these teams that form some of
organically in similar two teams in
industrial development that are
organized by managers in the last thing
that we did we looked at the difference
differences in discussion so we looked
at messages that were more technical
that mentioned things like function
names and files global variables and
then messages that didn't contain any of
these more technical terms so typically
we read those that didn't have technical
terms they were talking about more
process level things like should we
release this week or should Joe be given
access to the source code repository and
what we found so so the latter we called
process topics in the former we called
product topics we saw that the community
was much more modular when talking about
more technical things so
people were drawn to different parts of
the system and they would talk to other
people that were drawn to the same parts
of the system so again we've looked at
the community to try to test the
hypotheses and what we found is that
look the open source communities aren't
just ad hoc they actually organically
form into teams we did find the teams
are more dynamic than you typically find
an industry we found that when they're
talking about more technical things they
are even more modular they form into
these tight teams and also when I looked
at their actual development effort so
what they were actually talking about
what they were doing the changes that
they were making they were clearly
making changes relative to what they
were talking about in their organization
and so in some ways it's kind of a
validation of Conway's law that says
that the communication structure and the
architecture of a system are intimately
tied okay so that's that's what I've
done so what do I plan to do so a few
things so first one of the things that I
found is that the quality of the data
that you're working with is is directly
affect directly affects the power of the
conclusions that you're able to make so
he had a paper at FSU last year where we
looked at bias in data we found that
there is a lot of bias in a lot of data
that's used in research so in Apache we
looked at the number of bugs in
different Allah in a lot of ways but one
of the ways was in severity categories
and we found that for bugs that are
marked as more critical so maven the
blocker the critical no major categories
we're not able to tie those bugs back to
the bug fixes as often as the bugs that
are less important so than the minor and
trivial categories who actually found
that so this is this is clearly biased
so certain types of bugs are more are
over-represented and others are
underrepresented and when we looked at
at its effect on bug prediction and I
patha this testing we found the bias
data the amount of bias and the data has
a direct effect on the ability of the
technique to predict bugs and so right
now we just submitted a paper to FSC
where
where we actually try to recover ok it
doesn't like me we tried to recover
complete data sets and looked at the
effect of bias and how can we overcome
this bias get better prediction and so
this is one of the things that I'm
trying to look at is how do we deal with
this problems in data and I just
mentioned I think this is a problem here
as well gee Devon olya had a paper at XC
2009 where called the secret life of
bugs where they found that look a lot of
the data relative to bugs actually is
not being captured so this may have
implications on our ability to use this
data or rather how much better we can do
if we get the whole story and also we've
made I've made some findings here but
once we know things what we want to do
is actually remove the handle from the
pump like Jon Snow and see what we can
affect what can we change so we can make
make changes and observe make changes to
process and observe the results in cases
where we can actually make a change it's
not clear how to make the change we can
build tools to help people working on
software another interesting thing that
I one thing that I'm interested is
studying different domains so in in
research there are certain areas that
are over-represented in certain areas
that are underrepresented then I think
there's some areas of software
development that are very
underrepresented and if we haven't
studied them then we don't know what
laws of software development are
universal and which ones are
context-dependent so the two areas that
I think are hot right now that are
worthy of study our web applications and
game development and I'll tell you why I
think these are may be very different
from what we start in the past so web
applications you have multiple languages
running on running on different machines
so on the on the client you have
JavaScript and HTML on the backend you
have some type of database you may be
using SQL for queries in the middle tier
you may be running like c-sharp C++ Java
or some other new language so this is
very different than like an operating
system or a desktop application in
addition there's different schedules so
I know when websites called stack
overflow that's like a programmer help
website their goal is to release some
new feature a bug fix on a nightly basis
so every night they're deploying their
software again so this is very different
from like an you know windows where you
may be deploying you know a new version
every few years or even patches on the
monthly basis so if you can you can fix
bugs which very quickly which means that
testing may not be as much of an issue
but alternately if there's a bug that
brings down your site all sudden all of
your users are totally affected and then
rich monitoring so I talked to Jim lares
when you visit UC Davis and he said that
one of the most important milestones in
Windows development was when they added
Watson and they were able to view what
was affecting the developers the most
web applications you can even richer
view you know exactly what's being used
you know if there's a crash you know
what led to that crash you get a lot
more insight to the uses of your
application then you get in other
domains in game development there are
also some key differences so the amount
of content that ships relative to the
amount of executable code is very
different than a typical application
typically the content is order of
magnitude or more and to likewise the
team makeup is different so in cases
where there are tools that rely on ass
that rely on aspects of the source code
you may not have as much source code you
have people who I won't say are non
technical but their technical in
different ways because they're not
writing code they're creating content so
3d models and storylines so there may be
some implications relative to
coordination and how these people
interact and in addition the systems
that the software is running on is
different if you think of a web browser
you should be able to send anything and
even if it's malformed it has to be able
to display something to the user with a
game engine the content is fairly static
you know when you ship the game the
content that's going with it and so if
there you can test both of them together
and nowadays right there's downloadable
content but it's controlled so even then
if you find out what there's a bug in my
game engine that is exposed by this new
level well you can actually test that
level and make changes to it so it
doesn't expose the same bugs in the
engine so I think this may also have
some impact on on your QA so very
different from traditional development
and then lastly I've looked at the team
level but I'm interested in at the
individual level so right now you see
this proliferation of
new languages and language abstractions
to existing languages to deal with
things like multi-core some other
problems so if you look at like link was
just added to I guess not just was
recently added to c-sharp java's
introducing closures Twitter just moved
to skala as their implementation
language the people that are proponents
of this say look this this solves these
problems make they have lots of things
easier but it's not clear to me that
this is just a get something for nothing
when you introduce a new abstraction
that introduces some cognitive load on
the programmer and may be difficult to
deal with there are some projects that
decide look there's a new feature of a
language but we're not going to start
using that yet because we don't trust it
because that may be more difficult for
our developers so I'm interested in
looking at the effect of these new
abstractions in these new languages on
developers at the individual level and
then lastly i'm interested in
coordination I've only looked at the
team level but I'm interested in looking
at the individual level it's important
to know when you should be coordinating
and also when you shouldn't be
coordinating if you're always talking
about what you're doing and everybody's
doing this then you just have too much
noise and people stop paying attention
and the literature so far has just look
at things like number of lines changed
and commits and I'm interested in
looking at the semantics of changes that
people are making and determining when
certain semantics imply that you should
be coordinating your changes and with
who you should be coordinating with so
if you can direct it to certain people
rather than sending it to a mailing list
so this is kind of where I'm going and
share with you what I've done and I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
might have about things I presented here
also things in my papers or what I plan
on doing so I appreciate you coming out
and listening to what I have to say
thanks
so I've answered everything so why the
change changes that you are proposing
why haven't they been evaluated the
practice isn't because the proposals to
you or because there is no
infrastructure to measure whether things
we have impact or somesuch currently
it's mainly observation uh-huh but you
want to see that with your changes
things really oops oh go better so yeah
yeah okay so so when I was here over the
summer actually I wrote up some some
internal reports and I'm told by nochi
that that they actually have been have
gone to management and they have been
evaluating whether to put them into
practice honestly I don't know where
it's gone from there because I think at
that point its internal and as not a
Microsoft employee I'm not privy to that
type of thing but if I come here this is
clearly something that I'd like to do is
say you know who can we convince to deal
these recommendation I doubt people are
going to take no broad sweeping changes
and say now we're going to change how we
do windows right it's pretty risky but
you can start on on projects where it's
maybe less intrusive smaller projects
and see what the effects are but that's
that's part of why I want to be here is
because an industrial setting we can
make recommend changes right microsoft
research has a lot of reputation within
the company i know not she's done some
work that have actually impacted
development and that that's why I'm here
I'm comment about the liner contributors
who say instead of making the changes
themselves as they say go to a to an
owner or two major contributors I please
I'd like these changes what you make for
me or if they make them and then they're
carefully reviewed by but major
contributor and the ring is
effect might have on them on the time
that I'm required by the major
contributors base hope that major
contributor might be helped by having
other people also do stuff yeah so so
that's a good question right people
can't scale indefinitely and if you have
one person has to make every change this
is going to be a problem so one of the
things that I saw is that they're
oftentimes there's a clear owner there
are also other people who are not the
owner but have a fair amount of
expertise and when you increase those
number of people the software quality
went down but not tremendously and
nowhere near as much as in terms of the
number of minor contributors so I think
it's not just one person that you can
work with but a group of people but
clearly I wouldn't expect that there are
no minor contributors to any component
in the next release released if you're
aware of it you know when there are
spare cycles or a situation where look I
have time to review five changes there
have been 20 made now we can help you
prioritize where where to put your
resources and that's helpful those
debuffs introduced by minor contributors
who with it I mean
that was Adam a new contributors I mean
anyhow okay so i should be very careful
here I don't know exactly that the bugs
were introduced by those people so I'm
strong talking with people makes me
think this based on anecdotal evidence
but data I had to work with didn't
indicate this person introduced this bug
it's hard when you see a bug fix to
determine who introduced it because it's
not always the same lines so we have we
have strong reason to believe it but I
don't know that for sure because I
didn't have the access to that data I
don't know who made the fix I will say
this i know that microsomal put
everybody working on everything like you
have some free time go fix this bug in
this one thing in vista they they don't
do that there's still ownership at the
end of the cycle I should also point out
that we looked at the time to see maybe
all the minor contributions were coming
at the end and it's really it's it's
hiding this issue that it's not the
minor people it's just all stuff made in
the flurry at the end we didn't see a
large effect so vista I think was like a
six-year cycle the difference then the
median in the commits and it was it was
normal ish the median difference was
about 60 days between minor and major so
if you look at the distributions it says
heavy big overlap so this is some idea
of what's not causing the problem
so the data sources that you used for
your studies you're basically not
intended as measures for studies right I
mean you were basically looking at
things like the bug database and check
it yeah we're trying they're used for
some other purpose and we're trying to
use it for our own exactly exactly so
speculate for me so you know if you got
very high level buy-in from an executive
that you could put any instrument into
the work process you wanted to take
measurements different from what you can
get from the archives is there anything
you would want inserted what would it be
okay so anything about this so I just
actually just had lunch with Brendan he
said that there are some groups that
actually are buying it and saying what
you know what would you need to make it
better so I think this may happen what I
would like what would I like to see one
is I'd like to see why changes are being
made so if if a change is being made can
we say with confidence this is a bug fix
this is a feature edition you know
exactly who is making this change that's
probably the most important another
piece that I'm really interested in I've
looked at an open source is the idea
that I'm just looking at the repository
as this this black box we know that it
when you're doing development it's not
all on just one line of development
right people branch the code or work on
I don't know what the terminology is
here but not everybody's working the
same code base right I'm working on my
portion you're working on yours and then
at some point we're going to merge those
in or abandon them if they go wrong
right so I'd like to be able to look at
this level of granularity to get a more
complete picture so I think that can
tell us something about about how you
should how you should work and
coordinate your changes it may be that
if I'm working in a small team on our
own branch then that's better than these
I've Evans in the open source world that
that's much better than if you're all
working on one code base and I'd like to
actually empirically show that here at
Microsoft so that that's another piece I
think those two off the top of my head
you know give me till till tomorrow and
I'll probably have a longer list of you
know if I if you could have a candy
store what would you put in it because
yeah the more data you have the more
interesting you can ask your questions
thanks